[Applaudissements]
enora malagré voilà donc si vous voulez
quelque chose qu'elle vous servent
quelque chose c'est marc veyrat qui a
offert les voiles et les deux là
pourquoi
[Applaudissements]
et ce week-end ce week-end les chéris ça
n'était pas un week-end comme les autres
et oui c'était l'anniversaire d'une
personne que j'adore que j'aime par
dessus tout et qu une personne qui
m'aiment et que j'aime
il s'agit bien sûr de jean luc lemoine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et j'en ai
g j'ai un cadeau pour vous mais jean-luc
j'ai vraiment un cadeau pour vous je
vais vous d'offrir jean-luc une
croisière vers cadeau il et wendy hill
et il est en dessous non ce n'est pas
ben tiens voilà c'est ça donc jean luc
voilà je vous le dis bah je loue moi
même c'est une croisière sur la seine
avec la personne de votre choix sur la
scène
oui merci
[Rires]
c'est pas bien c'est
c'est un cadeau vraiment changé je
restais une vanne crois que c'était vous
allez me faire dormir sur la scène
pouvait y aller mot sur luc hennart et
je vous le dis alors vous allez nous
dire dans un instant avec qui vous
voulez y aller ça va mathieu
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]